et nous sommes à présent avec pierre
garnodier secrétaire général du comité
national des travailleurs privés
d'emploi et précaires au sein de la cgt
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation nouvelle mobilisation dont
convient d'en parler dans toute la
france aujourd'hui contre le recours par
le gouvernement aux à l'article 49 3
qu'est ce qui s'est exprimé dans les
rues l'hexagone aujourd'hui mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ce qui s'est
exprimé c'est d'abord là la volonté de
s'opposer à ce gouvernement qui refuse
le débat parce que le recours aux 49 3
il vient quand même juste avant qu'on
commence à étudier l'article 8 du projet
de loi qui concerne est quand même le
montant des passions et la valeur du
point donc le gouvernement sur les
points où il sait qu'ils cristallisent
l'opposition et où il est en manque
d'arguments et ben qu'est ce qu'il fait
il ne veut pas débattre et ihi bayonne
un peu le l'opposition qui elle avait
envie de déposer et de et de parler sur
le fond de ce projet de loi edouard
philippe il parle d' obstruction
parlementaire
ces quarante et un mille amendements qui
ont été déposés c'est quatre fois moins
que le nombre d'amendements qui ont été
déposés lors du projet de loi concernant
la privatisation par exemple d'edf est
le gouvernement de l'époque n'avait pas
recouru aux 49 3 voilà donc aujourd'hui
le le ce qui se passe dans ce pays c'est
que les travailleurs ils sortent pour
dire non nous nous voulons qu'ils aient
du débat parce que nous sommes opposés à
votre projet de loi sur les retraites on
vous dit depuis le 5 décembre
et lorsqu'il ya une enceinte qui peut
permettre de mettre en lumière tout
d'autres arguments et d'aller vraiment
sur le fond de ce projet doivent un
gouvernement qu est-ce qui fait il
éteint la lumière et puis dit à tout le
monde de sortir quoi de quels moyens
aujourd'hui disposent les organisations
syndicales la cgt que vous représentez
pour faire perdurer dans le temps sa
pression contre le gouvernement mais à
écouter déjà le premier moyen c'est là
c'est la grève là aujourd'hui quand même
alors que on a réagi assez vite un dell
annonce du 49-3 quand même il ya
plusieurs unions départementales de la
cgt et d'unions locales qui ont appelé à
des rassemblements locaux devant des
préfectures de vence idée d devant des
mairies et sur terrain dans beaucoup de
villes je pense notamment à toulouse à
lyon à marseille il ya eu des gros
rassemblement quand même dès le samedi
donc là aujourd'hui on est sur une
montée en puissance un peu de ceux de ce
conclave la mobilisation parme en compte
leurs cours et ensuite il va avoir deux
manières la poursuite de la mobilisation
contre les retraites avec une rude
journée d'action le 8 mars pour mettre
en parallèle la question du droit de la
femme des travailleurs des travailleuses
pardon et le projet de loi sur les
retraites qui va quand même cassé leur
future pension
voilà donc il ya une poursuite de la
mobilisation est toute manière nous 49,3
ou non la mobilisation et va se
poursuivre alors de moyens de deux
motions pardon de censure de la droite
et de la gauche sont débattues en ce
moment à l'assemblée nationale le député
la france insoumise de françois
deschamps s'est exprimé sur ces deux
motions de censure selon lui une motion
de censure c'est du bidon
je le sais je cite qu'est ce que vous
attendez vous de ces débats à
l'assemblée nationale
écoutez moi je crois que au delà des de
la motion de censure et du recours aux
49 3 il a quand même un débat a reposé
dans la société et dans les
chez pour les travailleurs c'est que
jusqu'en 1967 il y avait des élections
professionnelles à la sécurité sociale
parce qu'on considérait que la sécurité
sociale le film son financement ça
provient des cotisations donc c'est
notre salaire à nous en tant que
travailleur et donc l'état il n'y avait
pas à gérer ce budget là le général de
gaulle à confisquer ce pouvoir-là de
décisions des travailleurs sur leurs
salaires donc aujourd'hui on voit que
l'état y les gouvernements successifs
ils ne font que casser nos droits que ce
soit l'indemnisation chômage ou que ce
soit les retraites et donc il ya cet
enjeu là aussi démocratique a reposé que
ce soit par projet de loi recours au nom
du 49 3 en fin de compte est ce que
l'état est ce que c'est à l'état de
décider des retraites des travailleurs
qui sont financés par leurs salaires ou
est-ce que c'est aux travailleurs
eux-mêmes de désigner leurs
représentants et de décider de comment
est-ce qu'on va gérer notre salaire nos
retraites notre indemnisation chômage
lorsqu'on est malade bon voilà donc ça
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai débat et je
pense que le 49-3 il peut nous permettre
d'aller les discussions avec les
travailleurs et c'est ce qu'on fait deux
partout pour dire voilà que nous
qu'est-ce qu'on veut tenait le projet de
la cgt concernant la sécurité sociale
alors se pose aussi la question du
financement de la réforme des retraites
il ya une conférence du financement qui
est en cours force ouvrière a quitté les
négociations hier la cgt que vous
représentez a fait de même ce matin
qu'est ce qui a motivé
cette décision d'un autre syndicat
écoutez nous on a l'expérience des
négociations concernant l'assurance
chômage 7 s'était passé à peu près de la
même manière un gouvernement il avait
fait une lettre de cadrage et ils
avaient imposés les contours de la de la
négociation et là il nous refait en gros
la même recette pour les retraites en
nous disant de toute manière vous allez
pouvoir discuter de comment est-ce qu'on
va retourner à l'équilibré budgétaire
mais sans rien toucher à ce que nous
notre volonté et notamment sans toucher
aux recettes
donc on peut pas dire on va augmenter
les salaires pour apporter des nouvelles
recettes à vous pour les retraites on
peut pas dire qu'on va augmenter les
taux de cotisation pour apporter de
nouvelles recettes en retraite non donc
voilà c'est un semblant de discussion
est la volonté de la cgt et de
l'intersyndicale c'est de préparer une
sorte de contre conférence de
financement pour dire voilà nous on
répond aux besoins des travailleurs on
défend l'intérêt des travailleurs
de quoi est ce qu ont besoin les
travailleurs pour leur retraite et pas
de ce qu'a besoin le gouvernement pour
répondre aux appétits des financiers
merci beaucoup d'être percés répondre à
nos questions pierre un gars nodier je
rappelle que cette secrétaire général du
comité national des travailleurs privés
d'emploi et précaires au sein de la cgt
merci beaucoup